[Music]
on this Wednesday night Russia and China
solidifying their relationship as their
allegiance strengthens the U.S president
promises to protect NATO allies you know
better than anyone
what's at stake the BC woman scouring
the web to find weapons for Ukraine I'm
a Suburban among and I'm planning
Russian death
and cold snap the bitter weather
blanketing parts of Canada even Los
Angeles is under a blizzard warning
plus the changing face of the boarding
process this is the future Air Canada
Pilots a new project
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with a vow from the American
president to protect every inch of NATO
territory while China cements its
relationship with Russia China's top
Diplomat met the Russian president in
Moscow today saying China is ready to
deepen its strategic partnership China
is not formally supporting Russia's war
in Ukraine but the U.S fears it could
send lethal weapons in Poland the U.S
president was Shoring up alliances
pledging unwavering support for Ukraine
and NATO and continuing his diplomatic
standoff with Vladimir Putin
Mr President and your reaction to
including pulling out a new start
it was a big mistake start was the last
remaining nuclear arms reduction deal
between the U.S and Russia and on the
eve of the first anniversary of Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine Vladimir
Putin celebrated the war at a rally
called glory to Defenders of the
motherland Jackson prosco has our top
story tonight
Moscow the rallying Cry of a Nation at
War
first time
a joyful upbeat spectacle to Mark the
anniversary of Russia's bloody invasion
of Ukraine
[Applause]
headlined by Vladimir Putin himself
he led harass for the soldiers he has
sent to fight and die
families teach us he called the war a
battle for Russia's historical Frontiers
and for its people
soon after he held a subdued private
meeting with China's top Diplomat the
two countries pledged to strengthen ties
the West fears that could include
Chinese weapons for Russia's faltering
Ware on the other side of the conflict
in Poland Ukrainian refugees rallied for
more Western weapons to counter the
threat we need F-16 fighter jet and
enough weapons Supply to Ukraine to win
this evil to stop this awful War we're
all defend steps away the American
president met with the NATO members who
border Russia calling for Unity you know
better than anyone
what's at stake in this conflict not
just for Ukraine but for the freedom of
democracies throughout Europe and around
the world for the leaders in this room
the threat does not stop at Ukraine they
fear it could come to their own
countries and so Biden was told the U.S
needs to send more military equipment to
the Baltic states too it's the U.S
presence is important and this person is
going to be a
there also in coming years
one year into Ukraine's struggle for
survival there's a sense that the old
rules no longer apply a reignited battle
of East versus West that has left the
world on edge
the Jackson prosco Global News
Washington
for some perspective on that visit by
China's top Diplomat to Moscow gise is
with me he's a former Canadian
ambassador to China now a senior fellow
with the China Institute at the
University of Alberta Mr sejacques China
is talking about building a new type of
Cooperative relationship with Russia how
do you interpret that could it mean
China giving Military Support to Russia
China and Russia
have had many meetings where they have
discussed this new
multi-polar world and what they have in
common is that the the two believe that
the United States want to prevent
the rise on on the world stage and and
so they have been promoting this notion
of a multi a polar world at this stage I
don't think that China will want to
supply uh arms and ammunition directly
to Russia although it's possible that
they will use a proxy for instance it
would be easy for them to send Armament
and ammunition through North Korea and
the fact that the the the state
counselor for foreign affairs is in
Moscow today for talks is not a
coincidence clearly China wants to show
its support for Russia on the eve of the
anniversary of the invasion of Ukraine
the Chinese Diplomat who visited Moscow
today said China will oppose any
unilateral or bullying Behavior it
sounds like a dig at the U.S China is
good to speak on both sides of its mouth
because
they have started to to
mention that it's possible that they
will propose some kind of a peace plan
to try to
resolve the Ukraine Russia crisis and in
that they say for instance that one of
the Paramount principles will be the
respect for uh territorial integrity and
sovereignty well what do they made what
do they make of the fact that Russia
invaded an independent country and that
goes against this principle at the same
time they speak that it's important to
take into account the legitimate
security interests of of Russia let's
recall that just over a year ago when
Vladimir Putin was in Beijing the two
sides attack of uh of uh friendship that
would stand uh any anything and and
clearly China wants to continue to
support Russia what do you think is the
Strategic aim of China is it trying to
reshape the global order in its favor a
few weeks ago Xi Jinping has given an
important speech where he gives China as
a model for the developing world and he
said that modernization does not equal
westernization so for for him clearly
the message to uh to the world is that
the Chinese model is a good one to
emulate and and you don't have to to
adopt Western certain values to to make
progress and all this to say that it has
become more and more difficult to have a
dialogue with uh
Xi Jinping who's a an authoritarian
leader who runs a very aggressive
foreign policy all right former Canadian
ambassador to China thanks thank you
have a good rest of the day
now to the situation on the ground in
Ukraine since the invasion began Ukraine
has made multiple pleas to its allies
for lethal weapons without them the war
would be lost but it's not just Western
governments that are supplying them Jeff
Semple has the story of a woman in
British Columbia who is proving what a
difference one person can make
foreign
this team is testing a new weapon
they're members of a Ukrainian NGO
that's building drones for the military
to conduct surveillance and launch
attacks how important have drones been
in this war
[Music]
the person that is dominating in the air
is winning the war he says both sides
are now using and losing drones by the
thousands sparking a global scramble to
secure more parts and develop new
technologies in that high-stakes arms
race the ukrainians have found an
unlikely Ally
Kate McKenna is a mother of two who
lives in Suburban British Columbia every
morning she rushes her kids out the door
to school then sits down with her laptop
and finds weapons for Ukraine's military
it is very weird I I actually had that
moment where um I was like oh my God
what am I doing
I'm a Suburban Mom I'm planning Russian
death like a dear McKenna previously
worked as a VP at a global Investment
Bank and later for a Canadian drone
company not long after Russia invaded
Ukraine she quit to volunteer full-time
for United 24 a Ukrainian non-profit I
was born in Africa in Zimbabwe during
Civil War so I really understand what
it's like to lose your home using
LinkedIn and other platforms she's
created a network that includes retired
generals a North American manufacturers
and she's developed a knack for finding
mothballed military equipment
McKenna found these armored vehicles
sitting idle in an Alabama Warehouse
nearly 100 were just redeployed to
Ukraine
she found a cache of these anti-rocket
systems sitting in storage in Alberta
which she's now pushing to send to key
and last fall McKenna was given the
daunting task of finding Marine drones
that could move undetected on the Black
Sea where Russia was launching missiles
the result a fleet of these kayaks
rigged with explosives and propelled by
Canadian jet ski engines a dramatic
display of low-tech Ingenuity used to
attack the Russian Navy and so a lot of
what we do is a lot of duct tape and
putting things together and finding
unique ways to achieve the mission this
is just not how war was done but it is
now
the parts she sources end up in
workshops like this one where ukrainians
are custom building everything from
armored vehicles to drones this is
Ukraine's latest Innovation and it's
heavier than it looks the air 18 is
equipped with an infrared camera it has
a range of 10 kilometers and an altitude
of around 300 meters
while foreign governments and
bureaucracies can move slowly crafty
civilians like McKenna are helping to
meet the fast changing needs of
Ukraine's military
at the start of the invasion we needed
body armor and helmets now we need
Optics drones and demining Equipment
says ruslana velichko she's with the
Ukrainian charity come back alive the
civilian volunteers are importing arms
for the military
the group has used donations to purchase
armored vehicles air defense systems and
drones they're fighting a war against
Russia by donation and bargain Mason
hunting it's ridiculous but they're
succeeding following her success McKenna
now reports to an advisor to Ukraine's
Deputy Prime Minister in a statement he
told Global News Kate is doing an
incredible job for Ukraine she is an
ambassador helper supporter and
contributor if every person would be
like Kate there would be no war tyranny
would fall down the war in Ukraine is
being fought by Soldiers with drones and
by a Canadian mum with internet access
and an unrelenting drive to help Jeff
Semple Global News Keith
and Global News will Air a special on
Saturday at 7 30 to mark one year since
the full-scale Russian invasion of
Ukraine in Turkey there is overwhelming
amounts of work to do in the aftermath
of those earthquakes the UN said today
it will support the removal of debris
[Music]
it's estimated the disaster Left Behind
between 116 million to 210 million tons
of rubble work to clear it all away as
slow teams often have to pause to coax
out animals hiding in the collapsed
buildings the combined death toll from
the earthquakes in turkey and Syria is
now over 46 000 and millions of people
remain displaced there are questions
tonight about Canada's response to those
catastrophic earthquakes two Nova Scotia
brothers who lost their sister in the
Quake say the Canadian embassy in Turkey
let them down in their greatest hour of
need Ross Lord reports in on Tokyo
turkey a decimated City leads to
devastated families among them the Zora
Brothers of Nova Scotia they came here
to search for their sisters Summer she
was studying it on talk what when the
earthquake crushed the five-story
building where she was living summer did
not survive the search was extremely
stressful
and uh
now we're just figuring out how to
navigate average grieving the Zoras say
their anguish has been made worse by the
response from turkey's Canadian embassy
in Ankara as the Zoras made desperate
arrangements to fly from Canada to
Turkey to search for their sister they
say the embassy referred them to
websites sent them the same information
they had provided Embassy staff in
previous calls and warned them it was
too dangerous to come to Turkey they
came anyway and on their own organized
an excavation that uncovered their
sister's body they say they got more
help from the Kuwaiti Embassy even
though they are not citizens of Kuwait
you think that being a Canadian citizen
we'd be able to feel cared for and and
that didn't come until later with the
check-in phone calls right which was
not at all helpful but it was uh it was
something Global Affairs Canada did not
provide comment in time for our deadline
the government of Canada website says
International Consular Services include
providing advice and guidance if a
person is missing but it notes each case
is different and that events like a
natural disaster May mean we are less
able to help you the Zoras say less
service is better than no service and my
point of view they haven't done nothing
period I mean all that text messages and
the back and forth that you know with
the emails that's just a process but
nothing happened as they now raise money
for others directly impacted by the
earthquakes the Zoras say they're
grateful to friends in Canada who've
offered support they help other
Canadians never experience their ordeal
and their sense of disappointment in
Consular service
Ross Lord Global News
winter weather affecting Millions coming
up the Deep Freeze that's descended over
huge parts of North America
[Music]
more than 50 million Americans woke up
this morning to winter weather
advisories a severe storm system is
sweeping across the U.S thousands of
flights were either canceled or delayed
The Dakotas Minnesota Wyoming and
Wisconsin are some of the hardest hit
States in Arizona thousands of people
are without power and even in Los
Angeles there is a rare blizzard warning
the first in 30 years
harsh winter conditions are also
blanketing parts of this country
millions of Canadians are under weather
warnings Airlines say hundreds of
flights may be delayed or canceled as
Mike jorlay reports this large Arctic
blast is creating dangerous conditions
in a couple of major cities and for many
of the worst is yet to come
the sun might be shining but it doesn't
mean the roads are any less icy
it's been that kind of week in western
Canada
on Tuesday calgarians were celebrating
winter it was blizzarding but there's
fresh powder on the hill super nice 24
hours later windsport ski hill was
closed through Friday as temperatures
dipped below -30 for the homeless it's
been particularly dangerous the threat
of uh amputation is very real the threat
of death is very real for them so it's a
very like incredibly challenging time
the massive Arctic air continues to
freeze much of the Prairies but it's
expected to ease up before the weekend
the same can't be said of the other
system moving North from Colorado which
is much of the U.S Midwest prepping for
the worst minnesotans are Hardy it's not
our first winter snowstorm it won't be
our last winter snowstorm Ontario and
Quebec should take note because both
systems are headed east it's almost the
Collision then of these two uh
diametrically opposed air masses the
bitterly cold Arctic air shoving down uh
in in sort of Mid-Continent and then the
very moist tropical air coming out from
the Gulf of Mexico that's being
transported by this Colorado low so
these collisions of air masses causing
lots of weather across the U.S and
Canada as we speak the combined system
is already manifesting itself and
different ways in Ontario freezing rain
from Windsor up to Toronto which then
turns into ice pellets and then further
north from Perry Sound through the
Ottawa Valley snow but as the thermostat
dips above and below freezing those
winter lines become less clear
unlike out west where we can
definitively say it's just cooled
microlight Global News Toronto
[Music]
a deadly Israeli raid ahead who was
killed in the occupied West Bank and who
Israel was targeting
foreign
by the Israeli Army and the occupied
West Bank has killed at least 10
Palestinians
the Israeli military conducted the raid
on nablis in a rare daytime operation
Palestinians call it a massacre the
Israelis say they were targeting three
suspected men who they claim were
planning attacks at least three
civilians were killed in the clashes
including a 70-72 year old man and a 14
year old boy and more than 100 others
were wounded it is one of the bloodiest
raids in nearly a year in the West Bank
and East Jerusalem
there has been a collapse at an open pit
Coal Mine in China and it's believed
more than 50 people are missing under
the debris and at least two people have
died this video shows a plume of smoke
Rising into the air as the slope comes
crashing down more than 200 Rescuers
have been dispatched to the area the
open pit mine is in China's inner
Mongolian region a key area for the
country's coal mining industry
facing the future next Air Canada's new
biometric pilot project
[Music]
foreign
is testing new technology that would
eliminate the need to show
identification when boarding a flight a
face print is all you'd need it's a
pilot project and it's all voluntary but
biometric boarding is already being used
in other countries and gaviola explains
how it works and why privacy experts
have some reservations
no more hassle showing your ID and
boarding pass multiple times before you
board Air Canada is rolling out a facial
recognition pilot project to confirm
customer ID the feature matches the scan
of your passport's photo and chip with
selfies to authenticate identity it's
available for select flights departing
from Vancouver as well as the Air Canada
Cafe at Toronto's Pearson no absolutely
not no I wouldn't want them having my
face in their systems and all that I
prefer giving my IDs just my face
yeah I got down to hide Canada's
transport Minister applauded the project
in a joint statement with the airline
saying it has great potential to make
gate boarding easier and faster while
maintaining strong safety measures this
type of Cutting Edge technology is
already being used around the world
including the US and UK this is the
future you're seeing the future of air
travel evolve digital identification is
optional and the airline says biometric
data is encrypted and stored only on the
customer's mobile phone for up to 36
hours after the flight but there are
questions about what's at stake for
users this is very personal information
and is it safe especially if it's used
by a private company as opposed to being
run by an immigration services at a
border control for example Ontario's
former privacy commissioner urges
caution with personal information never
give up on privacy ever a lot of this a
lot of people out there naysayers they
say you know that ship of sale privacy
is dead the hell it is it's alive and
well and kicking and kavukian is calling
on Air Canada to be transparent about
how the information can and will be used
Air Canada referred Global News to its
terms and conditions which are available
for anyone to check out and gaviola
Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this Old Homestead in the
village of new dorf Saskatchewan east of
Regina we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]